well today I'm invited by ex matters in
their kitchen and travis de PUE is going
to walk me through how they went through
this journey of migrating from
monolithic application into
microservices on google cloud platform
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Travis for having me over
thanks coming awesome but I'm super
excited to actually cook with you today
and to eat because that's what I like to
do but before we do that I would love to
learn more about ex matters and what the
tool does we help keep digital services
up and running we do that by tracking
down the current on-call resources
delivering notifications to them and
letting them initiate workflow so what
the tool basically does is it takes the
times when there's spikes in traffic or
spikes in error rates and then it
notifies the right teams but that stuff
that's really hard to do how do you
understand all of that from and also
very complicated yeah yeah it is hard
and important to critical work you know
for the industries today and there's
once you get the notifications you know
that's just the beginning of the process
a lot there's a lot you know steps that
have to happen after that
and so that's called toil you know
important manual work that needs to be
done but it takes away time from
troubleshooting the issue so we can help
automate a lot of that process
this sounds obviously very exciting I'm
interested in seeing the tool can you
show me how this works yeah sure I have
a computer right here awesome
here we see part of the X matters flow
designer canvas showing a stack driver
alarm workflow the first step is the
inbound HTTP trigger that parses the
payload and kicks things off then we
start enriching the alarm with some
metadata that stackdriver might not have
in this case we're getting the Alaska
MIT and deployment info from github and
Jenkins and finally this is where we
actually fired the X matters event to
notify people
here we see Dan receiving the
stackdriver notification on his mobile
device he reviews the stock info from
stackdriver but then he can review the
enriched data from github and Jenkins he
has a couple different response options
but he decided this is severe enough
that he needs to roll back to the blue
deployment from the current green
deployment so he selects response option
and adds an optional comment
back in the ex Madras campus we see the
various flows that kick off when a user
selects develop relevant response
options each organisation has major
incidents and processes around kicking
those off in this case we see that ex
manners will automate creating a Jerry
issue and then a Status page incident
and finally a slack channel so the teams
can start collaborating we also see a
roll back to blue that Dan selected and
we see that a new dura issue is created
before triggering the redeploy using a
kubernetes command the JIRA issue helped
keep track of who triggered the
deployment and when and also serves as a
record for future investigation the last
one is my favorite though using a
playbook tools such as ansible we can go
trigger an existing playbook to attempt
to remediate the problem there are
limitless possibilities and all this can
be tailored in the specific processes of
the organization I can imagine how this
application must have looked originally
so I am super excited to learn how you
guys managed to take all these services
and separate them out and create micro
services out of them but before we do
that I want to know what we're cooking
today we're cooking vegetable soup and I
think it's gonna be pretty tasty okay
Travis so where do we start
I'm super excited looking at all these
veggies yeah we're gonna chop them all
up so we got some celery some parsley we
got some carrots and some cheese corn
and colorful Tomatoes ah good start
okay so Travis what do you think about
the difference between monoliths and
micro services how would you define it
well if you think of a monolith like a
turducken you know that meat monstrosity
that's the chicken inside of the duck
inside of the turkey mm-hmm a lot like a
turducken monoliths you know are very
intertwined everything's all put
together and rolling out new turducken
ziz very hard yeah you build each one
just like you know when you're trying to
build something and you have all the
things connected to each other and
they're dependent on each other and you
don't know which one to take apart
because the other things might might
mess up exactly got it okay conversely
micro-services are a lot like cupcakes
right if you have multiple plays or
flavors of cupcakes and you want to
change one little thing in the recipe
you can then change the recipe bake a
bunch of new cupcakes and your customers
get to have all the greatest and later
cappy's well that was the most delicious
explanation of the difference between
mullets and microservices that I have
heard so Travis what were some of the
main challenges that you all were going
through while you had this monolith
turducken setting of the architecture
I'm pretty sure there were challenges
that that made you think that moving to
micro-services was a good choice what
were some of those challenges well we
had monitoring and debugging challenges
so each customer essentially ended up in
their own instance and so trying to
track down issues and try and tell what
the health of the applications were was
really difficult we also found that it
was taking days if not weeks to get new
customers onboarding which certainly
isn't scalable I'm actually curious
about how the infrastructure was
initially when it was a monolid yeah so
originally we had CDs that we would send
out to customers we were you know as an
on-premise application so we decided to
take that and just put it into the cloud
naturally and unfortunately what this
meant is that we ballooned into 5,000
different VMs which as I mentioned isn't
it scalable yeah so as you start to have
5,000 VMs that definitely is a lot I'm
assuming you started to think you needed
to move to cloud what was that what was
that thought process like we rented
space in six different data centers
across the world so we we thought about
why are we getting into dealing with
hardware you know Google does that very
very well so why don't we leave it to
the experts what were some of the
architectural components at a high level
that you were looking at as a part of
micro services architecture yeah so
naturally we had the application was
composed of several different pieces so
we had the web user interface we had API
interfaces and we also have like a
notification services so being able to
reach out to email or SMS or voice calls
were all their own kind of service then
there was also the on-call scheduling so
trying to figure out you know who's
currently on call and so these were kind
of ie things we were able to identify
that we could pull apart and tease out
of the application to make them are
their own service when you aware start
to move to microservices what was the
end goal in mind primarily scale
maintaining 5000 BMS is just not
scalable so we try to identify different
aspects that we could pull out some of
the redundancy so for example we have
this application gateway that's feeding
traffic into the different services so
we're able to identify different places
that we can start to move to are
becoming resources and then so how did
that start to look in Google cloud from
the architecture perspective what are
the components you were using yeah so we
had a web user interface weird
application api's we had notification
services and on-call scheduling so all
these were different micro services that
we were able to pull out and break off
into their own into their own micro
service so application gateway approach
really sounds interesting and the
natural thing to do when you're starting
out with micro services breaking up your
monolith what are the components that
you ended up using on Google Cloud what
did the architecture look like so we use
Google DNS for IP I just look up and
then users are routed through the global
load balancer and then which gets them
into the application gateway so from
there the user devices such as web and
mobile devices are routed into the
various micro services that are all
running on gke
using images stored in google container
registry the data backend is running on
Google compute engine and we have the
monitoring running also using prometheus
let's plunk and of course stack driver
now when you decided to actually get the
gke services on what were some of the
services that you picked out or selected
from the monolith that that we're going
to go on as what was the decision making
process around that and what were some
of those services so the application is
composed of many different pieces so it
made logical sense to pull those
different pieces apart into their own
services so for example we have the web
user interface provides the web
interface you know for the various users
then we have the API interfaces as well
as like on call scheduling so it was its
own service to figure out okay who's
currently on call when an event comes in
and then there's the data services you
know keeping track of users and their
devices and things like that that brings
up a very inch
and a very important point when it when
you when it comes to my grading model
it's to micro-services because data
dependencies are key and every service
has some sort of dependency on another
service so this question always comes up
as to how do you actually define which
services should be migrated first or how
do you deal with those data dependencies
yeah certainly sir micro services you
know very rarely just in standalone
services you know they always depend on
other pieces so we just really made sure
to release the services in cadence with
each other as we as we started to build
out the application yeah so mainly just
making sure that you list out those
services that you may want to move to
micro services and then you define the
dependencies and then depending on which
ones dependent on each other or less
dependent on each other you define which
one goes first versus next well that
make that makes a lot of sense so we
have a bunch of chopped wedges here what
do we do next
we're gonna throw them in the pan and
then we'll add in the broth Oh awesome
let's do it
this definitely seems like a pretty
difficult and daunting task how long did
it actually take to finish out the
entire migration process
well once we made the decision to commit
the cloud it took us about 12 months
because we had data center contract so
we're coming up for renewal so it was
either get our stuff out or buy more
data center yeah yeah well those are
obviously very good situations to kind
of push you to where it's a good time
line was there a time when you were
running in GCP as well as in your
on-premise environment yeah we were
running them both up for about six
months the flexibility of the Google
cloud platform allowed us to do that
well it always seems that it's important
to understand that the beauty of
migration is you're not gonna just move
stuff from here to here it's always
going to be a gradual process where you
move some services over and you have
both platforms running for at least a a
considerable amount of time so you can
go back and forth between platforms
seems like that's what X matters ended
up doing you had six months in Google
Cloud and and also running parallely and
on-premises in order to facilitate the
migration can you talk a little bit
about the challenges or rather the
success metrics that actually meant to
that migration yeah so metrics are
critical you know we started with
monitoring and observability right out
the bat so that we knew that as we
introduced changes to the entire
environment we could see how they
impacted you know the different aspects
of the system so stackdriver I'm pretty
sure played a really big role in that
monitoring journey but I'm pretty
curious about a google kubernetes engine
and how did that play a role in those
incremental changes that as you were
gradually moving over to cloud so gk is
definitely the central part of our micro
services architecture we also use gke
VPC native IPS for direct addressing and
then we also use a sidecar pattern for
incremental deployments so Travis what
is the most challenging part of actually
moving into micro services pattern
sorting out the service ownership so
mapping the teams the different services
as well as deploying those services into
the environments we did touch a little
bit on like how to find out the service
that needed to be migrated and then
prioritize them in the sequence and all
of those things that that is really hard
to do should we check on our su because
I think that's like it's good man oh
yeah okay so let's do that so Travis
this change must have been really new
for the development and the operations
team because they are learning something
new moving into micro services they're
designing things differently they're
working on them differently the cadence
might be different how did you go about
making the development operations team
feel comfortable about the change you
know just humble talks about this really
well he says the bad behavior arises
when you abstract teams from the
consequences of their actions so we
really tried to align the teams with the
services that they had to build and
maintain so basically they will be
accountable for the SL O's if you give
them more ownership and more
accountability for the work that they
are doing so now that you've gone
through this migration what are the
impacts that you're starting to see well
happier customers mean happier teams
empirically we found that we had a 43%
performance improvement as well as 60%
less incidents well happy team and happy
customers definitely sounds like a win
to me apart from this as you are now
already into a Google cloud with the
micro services broken down from a
monolith what are you seeing as the next
steps where do we want to go from the
architectural perspective
well total domination of the market of
course well architectural a we will look
into moving into a service market tech
chure so you're probably using SDO and
that will allow us to get rid of this
application gateway and then let the
micro services talk to each other
directly
yeah so as much definitely seems like
the next logical step to take where you
can connect secure control and observe
your applications while in a micro
services fashion well Austin that was
very insightful Travis thank you so much
for having me over yeah thanks for
coming thanks for joining us today
I'm glad you were able to catch the
recipe of migrating a monolith to micro
services with X matters if you like this
video then stay tuned for more such
episodes
get cooking in cloud
[Music]
you
[Applause]